le couteau
restait encore à ça près on a senti sur
2 e mi-temps qu'on voulait vraiment
comprenant pris des risques et ont
vraiment marqué en attendant le match
lundi de trois face à auxerre dijon
s'est installée sur le toit de la ligue
voilà yohann rivière le nouveau buteur
du dfco son portrait est à découvrir
découvrir demain dans notre page sports
bourgogne c'est la fin de ce flash
d'information rentrée politique agitée
elle aussi on retrouve sans plus
attendre et lexicaux pour la seconde
partie de la voie est libre versez les
effectivement retour sur le plateau de
la voie est libre avec town aux quatre
invités laurent grandguillaume pour le
ps en studio pour le pc jean paul
orssaud pour l'ump et de l'arcal un pour
le front national n'hésitez pas vous
pouvez encore poser vos questions via
notre site internet via notre page
facebook ou sur twitter
est d'ailleurs va commencer par une
question d'un internaute j'espère qu'on
va pouvoir la voir boubou il s'appelle
en tout cas comme ça le président c'est
certain a beaucoup déçu mais comment
peut-on demander le retour de son
prédécesseur qui a perdu toutes ces
élections pendant son mandat n'a pas été
réélu a pas de casseroles qui laisse
filer ce que à droite il n'y a pas mieux
vous vous diriez oui peut-être jean-paul
earth ou simplement dans le nicolas
sarkozy quelqu'un qui est clivant chacun
le sait mais il est pour l'instant
encore ils étaient file ci symbolise au
sein du mouvement le chef que personne
na na na su incarner comme lui et
aujourd'hui encore moins qu'hier
par contre et on peut quand même porté à
son actif le fait comme président il a
su apporter sa contribution elle était
majeure au niveau européen et mondial au
moment de la crise de 2008 chez nous la
commune également plus le organiser le
sauvetage des banques et ensuite les
banques ont remboursé l'état qui a
permis de tenir il a quand même il a
quand même réussi un certain nombre de
choses alors maintenant nicolas sarkozy
s'il souhaite revenir d'ailleurs rien ni
personne ne l'en empêchera au moins
jusqu'à la direction de l'ump
s'ils se présentent je vois
difficilement qui peut se présenter en
face de lui et le battre ensuite pour le
tour suivant à savoir
les primaires de 2002 pour l'élection de
2017 ça c'est autre chose mais on peut
pas moi on peut pas dire que nicolas
sarkozy ait quelqu'un qui n'a pas bien
on plie son mandat de président comme
d'autres qu'il a commis des erreurs il a
fait des fautes mais on peut aussi faire
porter à son actif un certain nombre de
réussites le ps voit sa dernière plutôt
de nicolas sarkozy qu'elle ait pas une
cote de popularité énorme quand il était
président montre il appartient à
l'opposition de se relayer moi j'ai pas
de jugement porté souvent ce que ce que
je constate c'est que cette droite on va
dire bonapartiste qui attend le retour
du chef veut provoquer une crise de
régime parce que comme cela ça
permettrait peut-être le retour du 16
c'est pour ça qu'ils sont nos discours
de crise d'origine discours ce petit
discours que l'on entend en permanence
mais par contre quand vous dites qu'il a
sauvé les banques je vous rappelle quand
même que c'est monsieur sarkozy qui a
créé en france les sub prime sont les
produits qui ont conduit à la crise
financière mais il les a mis en place en
france en 2007 alors nous on les a
supprimés oui quand on vous dit qu'on a
rien fait
effectivement on a supprimé les
hypothèques charial créée par monsieur
sarko effectivement on est revenu en
arrière
fallait
il a créé les suprêmes en france les
hypothèque rechargeable
bah oui c'était la possibilité pour les
français de lui donc d'emprunter jusqu'à
50 anglo saxons qui n'avait qu'une
hypothèse
explique t il au micro jardins de
l'hypothèque rechargeable c'est la
possibilité en france jusqu'à cette
année de financer un crédit à la
consommation avec une hypothèque
recharger jusqu'à 50 ans voilà et ben
oui c'est bien mais c'est pas
dans celles où
françois diot ou le renvoi des os qu'il
voulait réagir à ce truc qu'on vienne
voir à l'antenne les frondeurs vent à la
fête de l'huma fricoter avec mélenchon
qui insultent hollande à longueur de
journée bravo les gars comme choc
parti communiste avec les écologistes
les radicaux de gauche c'est normal
c'est bien que des parlementaires
eux-mêmes salutaire à noter aujourd'hui
il n'y a rien de plus urgent que de re
rassemblés autour d'un vrai socle de
gauche moi ce qui se passe à l'ump on
commet moi je suis pas un commentateur
la vie politique je suis un acteur de la
vie politique souhaité à quai et dans la
situation d'aujourd'hui effectivement
que sarkozy puisse se permettre de dire
je vais revenir et les problèmes quoi je
pense qu'il faut tout faudra tout faire
pour barrer la route au retour de la
droite et pourquoi est ce que
aujourd'hui c'est une possibilité c'est
justement parce que la gauche d soit
parce qu'un gouvernement de gauche
tourne le dos à ses engagements et qui a
pas la rupture annoncée avec ce qu'a
fait nicolas sarkozy moi en écoutant ps
ump fn tout le monde rivalisent dans
l'austérité tout le monde est là je
supprimerai
national ne veut pas augmenter les
salaires nous proposons de la
formalisation des mendiants
l'ascension
innovation du remboursement de lille et
j'ai c'est la suppression de l'aide
médicale d'état c'est le retour de la
peine de mort bref c'est un capitalisme
nationaliste le fond si vous voulez le
peuple n'a pas de leur demander leur
avis sur l'agression
dont président français la solution si
vous me permettez que parler parce que
moi je respecte la démocratie
la solution elle est dans la
reconstitution d'un réel programme de
gauche qui a été demandé par le français
et qui fait défaut aujourd'hui les
50 milliards de réduction des dépenses
publiques de 20 milliards de cadeaux aux
patrons sans aucune l'avait demandé
qu'on vous écoute si vous lui remettrez
donc en fait l'austérité par exemple en
espagne ça a été la baisse du traitement
des fonctionnaires c'était la
suppression des primes c'est pas le cas
en france en france l oppression été
voté par exemple pour augmenter le
traitement des fonctionnaires qui ont le
moins comme il y aura une baisse de
cotisations aussi même si le conseil
constitutionnel l'a censurée de
cotisation et les salariés qui ont les
plus bas revenus voilà donc c'est pas
l'austérité je veux dire il faut aussi
qu'on soit quand même logique et qu'on
sorte un peu de notre débat national
parce que sinon on regarde ce qui s'est
passé autour en europe oui il ya eu des
politiques d'ajustement qui nous l'a
cette austérité faut quand même le
rappeler et il me semble que les
français aux dernières élections renault
michelin ont particulièrement racheter
l'union européenne en tant que telle en
tout cas aujourd'hui alors vous qu'il
entend le front national au plus haut
niveau vous qui dites que vous verrez
c'est ça il ya vis de nous demander
comment faire avec un parti qui
finalement est un parti familial on peut
se le demander en tout cas dit il les
milieux elle parce que la fille a repris
le parti en cavale peur à l'époque elle
a été élue le centre démocratiquement au
sein d'un congrès à d'ailleurs ce
congrès et au mois de novembre
il se peut très bien que quelqu'un se
présente face à marine le pen pour
l'instant il n'a pas ma connaissance
mais c'est tout à fait possible
pourquoi moi même me présente et si
l'envié m'en prenais je n'ai pas cette
prétention mais je veux dire marine le
pen elle a été élu démocratiquement au
sein de ce parti on nous parle toujours
de népotisme parce que les deux
s'appelle le pen vont c'est le père la
fille c'est comme ça c'est une réalité
sont frédéric mitterrand aurait pu
reprendre au ps personne ne se refuse
pas tort au gouvernement donc un sondage
aujourd'hui pour itélé le parisien vous
l'avez lu peut-être 65% des français
pensent comme fn n'est pas capable de
gouverner vous avez peut-être aussi dans
le monde cette semaine que certains
cadres du fn disent eux-mêmes que le fn
n'est pas capable de gouverner n'a pas
assez de réseaux pas le le potentiel
humain
répondre très clairement là dessus
aujourd'hui ce front national à d il ya
des gens qui gravitent autour de marine
le pen qui sont je crois parmi les plus
grands spécialistes de france il est
vrai par rapport à ce que vous me dites
que nous manquons d'une certaine
implantation locale je pense qu'il y a
largement assez de ministrables au front
national ou mais nous manquons d'une
implantation locale c'est ça sera chose
faite je pense avec les futures
régionales et des futurs départementale
nous allons asseoir cette implantation
mais tout ça il me semble que c'est
dérisoire côté français nous écoutent
parce que la réalité des preuves c'est
qu'il faut leur trouver des solutions à
ces problèmes que ce que vivent les
français il faut aujourd'hui
arrêter cet engrenage de l'austérité de
la baisse des salaires etc il faut
retrouver un vrai souffle et je crois
que c'est ce souffle on peut retrouver
uniquement par la dissolution et je
l'espère que le front national se
retrouve promis en cas de législatives
pour
gouverner non pas avec françois hollande
comme j'ai pu l'entendre car certains
commentateurs mais contre françois
hollande justement l'ump a fait savoir
que si elle était première aux
législatives elle ne souhaiterait pas
gouverner contre certains incertain
oui mais quand même beaucoup j'ai trouvé
je trouvais que c'était un manque de
responsabilité cruel c'est à dire que si
les français les portes au pouvoir il ne
voudrait pas s'en occuper eh bien nous
on a dit clairement marine le pen l'a
dit clairement on prendra havre à bras
le corps les managed les dires pour
essayer de faire ce qu'on peut pour une
précision à face à lens au sol sur la
dissolution de ma position personnelle
je suis pas le seul à l'ump c'est à dire
que dans l'hypothèse d'une dissolution
évidemment si les français portent une
nouvelle majorité il est clair que la
constitution prévoit et surtout
cela va de fait que le président du parc
du premier parti d'opposition
accepte de devenir le premier ça la
réalité c'est ce que chirac a fait c'est
ce que j'ose pas fait cesser cela m
c'est comme ça que ça doit se passer
quant à la dissolution il ya trois cas
de figure premier cas de figure soit
effectivement avec les frondeurs avec l'
amalgame d'un certain nombre de
situations qui est propre au parti
socialiste la confiant à un moment donné
le premier ministre a mis en minorité
vote de confiance budget ou autre peu
importe et à ce moment là vont là le
gouvernement tombe deuxième si tu as le
deuxième cas de figure c'est la rue
parce que à un moment où le système est
bloqué système économique conflits
sociaux s'est bloqué et trois échappés
troisième solution c'est une dissolution
le tapis parce que monsieur hollande
aura décidé à un moment de faire en
sorte de 10 ou de la tombe nationale
pour faire un book de co2 cohabitation
essayer de se refaire une santé pour les
derniers mois vous y croyez est-ce qu'on
est donc politique est-ce qu'on est dans
la politique fiction sa petite
politicienne moi ce qui m'intéresse
c'est par exemple la réforme sa
transition énergétique qui va arrive en
débat c'est la réforme sur l'autonomie
vous avez la question d'indépendance que
vous deviez la promesse qu'on n'a pas
tenu par exemple donc ce sont des sujets
qui sont importants qui touchent
beaucoup de françaises et de français et
c'est tout ça qui est intéressant parce
que les dissolutions les tactiques et on
en a ras-le-bol en a ras-le-bol
pas d'emploi en parle pas de logement
parle pas d'éducation pas patiné parler
que de dissolution l'heureux
président la récente
can intérêt aujourd'hui sera contraint
mais légitime voire un dernier sondage
il n'ya plus qu'à % des français qui ont
tout à fait confiance en lui
et moi ce que l'on peut pas dit quand
même tendance à la mobilité des français
en france et sur le terrain aujourd'hui
mais les français
on a dit ça ici olivier que le
disqualifier si vous avez
la question c'est l'emploi le logement
l'éducation la santé voilà la question
des services publics notamment
maintenant mes
dd réorganiser
efficacement
comme ça que ça fonctionne
france a durci françois hollande et me
hantera si manuel valls est mis en
minorité au vote de samedi y'a pas
automatiquement dissolution un vote
contre à l'assemblée nationale ça
implique simplement le changement de
scénario et le changement de
gouvernement c'est le président de la
république si vous nous permettait de
parler
[Musique]
c'est le président de la république
qu'elle décide ou non de dissoudre et on
est dans un système de la vème
république où c'est le monarque
présidentiel qui quand l'assemblée
nationale 10 kg qui dit qu'elle n'est
pas d'accord et ben dissous l'assemblée
nationale s'ils pouvaient dissoudre le
peuple des fois on se demandait si la
solution c'est de changer de politique
envers une politique conforme à ce que
la majorité de l'assemblée nationale
pourrait demander dans le cadre d'une
majorité qui existent aujourd'hui je le
répète majoritaire aux rosaires qui
pourrait augmenter les salaires qui
pourrait s'attaquer à la finance qui
pourrait enfin remettre de la doller
vrai dans la machine économique
de quelle majorité
c'est sur un programme monsieur ont fait
pas parti de la majorité vous
on cherche la conserverie des sommes des
gones en français c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui français vont se
détourner de vous parce que vous les
avez travaillé je leur ai dit une fois
de plus vous avez travaillé le monde
ouvrier vous avez trahi tous les
français on attend en tout cas si j'ai
bien compris et laurent robin
gouvernement continue de gouverner
l'assemblée continue de faire c'est de
travailler tout simplement de travailler
voilà offensif et c'est pas facile bien
évidemment parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
problèmes à régler mais il faut pas
penser qu'on va démissionner quand les
difficultés mais ce cabaret donc on va
et on met où on est dans le combat
politique pour l'action qu'il est même
si ça vous déplaît
c'est pas moi que ça déplaît encore une
fois c'est des français dans les
prochaines
arrivées au terme de cette émission déjà
merci en tout cas tous d'avoir participé
de façon rigoureuse à cette émission je
vous rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet bourgogne point france 3 point
fr la semaine prochaine ce sera un
invité unique qui participera à cette
émission l'occurrence le ministre du
travail françois rebsamen pour l'heure
le 12/13 se poursuit avec l'actualité
nationale et internationale
merci à tous merci de votre fidélité et
dans l'après midi sur france ô
[Musique]
où
pendant
il